summer blockbuster season really kicks
off on may 27th with the arrival finally
of top gun maverick and if you're
wondering what it's like to go to tom
cruise flight school well now we finally
know
three
two one
well tom on top gun put together the
entire flight regimen i started them out
in the single-engine airplane
to build up their spatial awareness next
we took them to the l-39
from there they'd graduate to the f-18
super hornet it was just all about
g-tolerance getting you know getting to
the point where you just keep working up
the g's so you don't black out when
you're actually up there we worked with
the navy and the top gun school we were
on the carrier the uss theater roosevelt
we were on that thing for two weeks
sleeping in a bunk probably you know
come on 30 feet below where they're
launching you know they're launching
jets so the whole bunk is you know it's
just like
the navy says if you eject you have to
be able to survive in the water so we
had to go through that challenging
underwater program
the three-month program included
underwater training and this verified
cameras
the actors also had to learn how to run
the cameras because when they're up in
the jet they have to direct themselves
essentially i mean this aerial footage
will never be replicated again but like
a kid every single day like i literally
felt like i was playing pretend every
single day there's five g's
[Music]
you